the jurogan experience
you know when they get rid of it right
why black people really mm-hmm that's it
so yeah this is actually this is holy
stones okay hold these thoughts tell me
when you're good
okay did you get that already oh jamie
already got that all right let's
just finish the yeah so uh the reason
the 45 caliber bullet exists and the
reason they got rid of coke or the
reason they
made cocaine illegal is because when
blacks were working the docks
in the late 1800s early 1900s um
they had these things there was a rape
obviously that's what always happens
right
emmett till all of them right so uh one
reported a rape
and uh a cop it came up and then he was
there's a
black dude on cocaine because they would
give the doc workers cocaine to keep him
up all night
yeah that's when it was legal and then
there was a uh
a coked up black dude right real big
dude i guess and uh a woman was saying
he's chasing me right and he was just
he was i don't know what the [ __ ] was
going on but the cop was shooting at him
and there was no stopping power enough
except for the bullet so they'd make a
bigger bullet
uh the 45 caliber bullet because what
they're using like some
a little over a 22. damn and you know
this is some real [ __ ] because this is a
crackhead back in the day i shot the
[ __ ] nine times with a tech nine and he
kept running down the alley different
different crack though
different colors that was correct that's
it that was coke this was right yes
there's no cocaine
cooking crack according to carl hart
they're the same thing
they are the same thing one just really
one just has baking soda that's all
it's just you're just freeing the base
of the powder that's why it's called
free base
yeah you know what i'm saying she
probably made it famous yeah crack it
crackers
cocaine craze negroes that's what they
called them the difference is the
the in sentencing that's the difference
the difference in sentencing it's
crazy yeah powder to yeah that's right
it's crazy didn't obama change that [ __ ]
somebody must i hope i don't believe
it's the same anymore i think obama
changed it i think i want to say he did
but i don't know
if the the same sentencing for crack and
cocaine you know that's the same [ __ ]
they did with marijuana yeah when
william randolph hearst was trying to
make marijuana illegal
they put out these stories saying that
black and mexicans
exactly were raping white women and they
blamed it on this drug they blamed it on
marijuana when marijuana wasn't even
called marijuana back then
the marijuana was a wild to mexican
tobacco
so they made this new name so when
congress was making
marijuana illegal they didn't even know
they were making hemp illegal the i
what the target was was hemp the
commodity they were trying to make the
paper illegal
and they were trying to make the
textiles illegal because william
randolph hearst not only did he run
hearst newspapers
but he also had paper mills and then on
the popular popular uh science magazine
on the cover it said hemp
the new billion dollar crop because they
came up with a new way of processing it
called a decorticator and so when they
invented this decorticator
it's exactly the same kind of thing
right and then when they invented this
thing
people were all going to start growing
hemp and they would have superior paper
it's better for clothing and william
were handed off first like not so fast
really he made it all illegal so that he
could just keep his paper mills
and keep making him with wood and keep
using all the things that he's already
used before instead of him controlling
the industry that's amazing that they
could literally just say that about
black people
we're raping everybody well we got to
get rid of it then didn't really made up
a name for the plant
or the plant already had cannabis it was
so like they called it marijuana it was
like oh my god like bath salts
like oh jeez it's a new thing what is
this
pcp that's that's what you know pcp
is the same thing as ketamine yeah i
didn't know that either
yeah academy special k when i went to
australia that's all the [ __ ] were
snorting they had no real cocaine but
it's a tranquilizer
they were starting all ketamine i said
they said you want some coke i said that
ain't real coke i said we are all the
way
in australia we are thousands of miles
from columbia you don't have real
cocaine here i don't believe it they
don't get real cocaine
no no they snorting special k really yes
keto meat okay
because they i every time i go out there
they always have coke but i'm like
there's no way
you know what all the big colombian drug
dealers they ain't [ __ ] with america
no more they going to europe
it's easier easier to import the drugs
the easier yeah it's way you they making
way more money
and you get less time when i was locked
up in europe you know what i'm saying
for that [ __ ] i was like
yeah it's crazy like it was guys in the
cell
that was there on drug offenses and i'd
be like damn how much you get called for
uh they're like man i got called with
like four keys and i'm like damn
i'm like how much time you about to get
he's like 18 months i'm like what the
way it should be
that's what i'm saying but you get
caught with that over here
eight years you're doing 18 years keller
winslow junior is getting 14 years for
rape who is kellen winslow jr
keller wins those son right he played uh
he played for miami he raped somebody he
raped he gave me rapey vibes yeah
he raped uh homeless women oh yeah like
in their 50s
jesus yeah give him uh yeah give him 20
years yeah
he got 14. he should i'm saying bro it
should be 30. it shouldn't be like you
know because if you yeah if
i go four kilos i'm probably going to
jail for 30 years definitely for sure
see what i mean
if i rape a woman three women i'm going
for 14 years yeah the thing about kilos
and they'll get rid of cocaine the other
thing about kilos is like it's only
valuable if somebody wants to buy it
right right like somebody has to want it
like you're not really doing anything
wrong
you're just getting something to them
that they want you're not
really hurting them no you're you're
allowing them
yeah you're allowing them to do coke
right and how many
i mean if you were just doing coke
that's the thing that's my yeah the
thing about coke is like
if you're just doing coke like real coke
not all this cut up [ __ ]
this is the other thing that dr carl
hart who's he's actually a professor at
columbia and
uh that does uh heroin does heroin yeah
okay yeah
he's eating that [ __ ] i was like what
the [ __ ] he said i'm functional
interesting guy
oh yeah because he's first of all he
wasn't doing any drugs at all until in
his 30s
when he was a research scientist and he
realized while he was studying these
chemicals
that all the propaganda were spreading
about him was all [ __ ]
so he started trying them i mean
everything's better in moderation man
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify you can listen to
the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience